Bom
[Música]
dia três de março de 2021 foi o dia mais
difícil da minha vida
nós começamos com dor de garganta dor de
cabeça fraqueza e diarreia
Diagnóstico como você pode imaginar se
chama covid-19
e como enfermeira eu cuidei de toda
minha família meu pai minha mãe meu avô
e minha avó meu pai e minha avó tiveram
sintomas respiratórios moderaram agravo
e
e na vida se lindas a UPA eu me vi um
campo de guerra
famílias acampadas
pais irmãos filhos
tá chorando à medida que anunciavam a
informação de um familiar querido
e eu e minha mãe a gente já aguardava
ansiosa lá fora em busca de uma notícia
do meu pai naquele dia na troca de
plantão o médico me chamou e deu a feliz
notícia que meu pai serial
Voltamos para casa felizes animados E
conforme avançávamos às quadras em
direção a nossa casa a saturação de
oxigênio do meu pai foi caindo
85 porcento
Oi e a minha esperança minha pressão
também caíram eu olhei para minha mãe e
falei vamos voltar para o
e a partir desse dia foram quinze dias
de oxigênio em casa de
medicamentos e Fisioterapia
eu logo na primeira semana me recuperei
é mas conforme os dias foram passando me
tornei muito cansada Ficava muito
cansada porque o cuidado de todos em
casa minha casa se tornou o verdadeiro
hospital com cinco passem eu verificava
a oxigenação de todos durante a noite e
Eu praticamente não dormia e foram dias
e noites assim eu fiquei em Pânico
a administrar os medicamentos
abraçava minha avó quando fazer inalação
nela e ela dizia a sua mão tá tão
quentinha coloca no meu pulmão eu me
sinto melhor respiro melhor
a e os dias foram passando e eu fazia
dezenas de orações para recuperação dele
e aquelas noites também eu lembrava das
pessoas com doenças raras no qual eu
acompanho há 18 anos você conhece alguém
conversa Rara bom
aquelas cenas de terror para mim era o
cotidiano de muitas dessas famílias
e as mães com esses raras que eu
conhecia eu me fortalecido nela pensava
nelas para continuar
e eu lembrei também que segunda
interfarma a no Brasil 13 milhões de
pessoas com doenças raras que buscam
busca no diagnóstico
e na família Tim diagnóstico
e as pessoas com doenças raras podem
levar até 10 anos para se obter um
diagnóstico com sintomas por exemplo com
o são pneumonias frequentes tosse
crônica inchar E dores insuportáveis por
exemplo
a minha família tinha um tratamento
tinha Orientação médica
mas para uma família com doença Rara às
vezes pesadas são altas e podem acabar
com todos os seus recursos que não
servem
perderem suas casas vender esse terreno
eletrodomésticos e tudo tudo que elas
têm
E além disso tem um gasto emocional
uma vez uma mãe me contou ao receber o
diagnóstico da filha de
mucopolissacaridose a médica informou
que a filha feriu prazo de validade de 2
anos
os objetos sem prazo de validade pessoas
não as pessoas são únicas repletas de
características que as tornam especiais
assim como eu e você
e as pessoas com doenças raras merecem a
mesma atenção de pessoas com doenças
comuns
o rolo vistas isoladamente essas doenças
são poucas parecem poucas e por isso
também que tem pouco Impacto social o
creas pesquisas que desenvolvem
Tecnologias para ela
é mas quando somada segunda é Osório São
mais de 7.000 pus de doenças raras no
mundo há 300 milhões de pessoas com
doenças raras e quando eu olho os dados
do IBGE
eu verifico que o Brasil tem 211 milhões
de habitantes e esse juntarmos todas as
pessoas raras do mundo
o frio mais numerosas que o nosso país
inteiro
e as necessárias não são contagiosas
muito diferente da curva 19 que também
tem o preconceito em relação infectadas
a e os nomes dessas doenças são até
difíceis de pronunciar como por exemplo
fenilcetonúria osteogênese imperfeita
epidermólise bolhosa doença de crochê
angioedema hereditário doença de fabry
toda essa reflexão sobre a vida das
famílias com doenças raras me deu forças
pra enfrentar a cor verde 19 na minha
família
e eu sabia que
essa infecção teria descontados na minha
família
e hoje eu estou vacinada
Provavelmente você também estará daqui
uns dias e daremos a Deus juntos a mais
uma pandemia na história
é mas as pessoas com doenças raras
permaneceram uma pandemia de ar
atrás de uma máscara
tem uma vacina para amenizar a doença
muitas vezes tem um tratamento para
controlar os sintomas da doença sem um
benefício para os pais que muitas vezes
perdem seus empregos diante a rotina
exaustiva de cuidados e consultas
médicas
bom então eu desejo
O que é essa pandemia acaba que você a
poi
13 milhões de pessoas com doenças raras
para que ela saiam da pandemia da
exclusão social
conta com você